9 серпня в Білорусі відбудуться президентські вибори.
Чим ці вибори відрізняються від інших?
Аби залякати людей, влада застосовує адмінресурс.
І чинить тиск на виборців ще задовго до виборів.
Дуже сильний тиск проти населення, протестувальників,
учасників виборчого процесу, в тому числі спостерігачів.
Такого раніше не було до дня голосування.
Такі репресії були в 2010 році після виборів.
Цей сильний тиск шокує.
ЦВК не зареєструвала кандидатами в президенти трьох головних опонентів Лукашенка.
Це Віктор Бабарико, який раніше очолював "Белгазпромбанк".
Валерій Цепкало, що входив в команду Лукашенка на виборах 1994 року.
А також популярний відеоблогер Сергій Тихановський.
Я заявляю про свій намір брати участь у виборах президента як кандидат.
Бабарика та Тихановського ще до виборів взяли під варту.
А Цепкало втік з країни
Однак ЦВК несподівано зареєструвала кандидатом у президенти дружину Тихановського
Сергію, я тебе дуже сильно люблю.
Я це роблю заради тебе і заради людей,
які за тобою пішли, які в тебе повірили.
І заради всіх, хто ще приєднається до нашого руху.
Спостерігачі від ОБСЄ не присутні на виборах,
тому що отримали запрошення з великим запізненням.
Не будуть спостерігати за виборами і представники Росії та інших країн.
ЦВК Білорусі обґрунтувала це тим,
що не може забезпечити їхню безпеку в умовах пандемії.
Не дуже зрозуміло тоді, чому вибори проводити можна,
а спостерігачів запрошувати не можна.
Виборча кампанія проходить на тлі пандемії коронавірусу.
Олександр Лукашенко спочатку заперечував існування COVID-19.
Я коронавірус цей називаю не інакше як психозом
і від цього вже ніколи не відмовлюся.
Бо разом з вами пережив уже багато психозів.
І ми знаємо, до чого це призводило.
Абсолютно переконаний, що це один із таких психозів,
який буде на руку комусь, а комусь і на шкоду.
На момент цього висловлювання ВООЗ вже оголосила про пандемію коронавірусу.
Європейські країни одна за одною вводили обмежувальні заходи.
Але Лукашенко продовжував грати в хокей при повних трибунах.
Тут немає вірусів ніяких!
Ось ти ж не помітила, що вони літають?
І я теж не бачу!
Олександр Лукашенко відреагував, з точки зору населення, неадекватно.
Не вводилися обмежувальні заходи, як у Швеції.
Але населення побачило, що ситуація вийшла з-під контролю.
Небезпеку заперечували і занижували,
коронавірус порівнювали з грипом.
Але кожен білорус особисто знав когось, хто потрапив до лікарні,
у кого було запалення легень, хто сильно хворів.
На мітинги Світлани Тихановської приходять тисячі людей.
Не тільки в столиці, але й у невеликих містах.
І це попри те, що влада жорстко затримує учасників протестів.
Правда полягає в тому, що в 2015 році
у Олександра Григоровича було 50 плюс відсотків голосів.
І ніколи не було 50 мінус.
А тепер у нього буде 50 мінус - і все.
І саме поведінка влади нині показує, що вони це знають краще, ніж я.
Незалежної соціології в Білорусі не існує вже з 2016 року.
Ніхто не знає цифри щодо реальної підтримки президента в країні.
Але те, що є готовність і бажання до змін, це, я думаю, всім очевидно.
І було би дуже правильно і розумно, якби режим знайшов відповідь на це.
Не тільки тиск, а й реальні відповіді.
Інакше ситуація і для самого режиму навряд чи поліпшиться.
Але Олександр Лукашенко, схоже, не збирається віддавати владу.
Ми створили свою країну, де можуть жити наші діти.
Сьогодні той момент, коли треба її відстояти, треба захистити.
Ви бачите, що нас на частини розривають.
Єдина пострадянська країна, яка не бачила горя.
На нас, міцному монолітному суспільстві,
вирішили відпрацювати ось ці кольорові революції
з урахуванням нових інформаційних технологій. Не вийде!
Мабуть, за всю історію правління Лукашенка - а це 26 років! -
результат виборів не був настільки непередбачуваний, як тепер.